welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it looks like
Jun sure is the month for sentient toys
with Toy Story Chucky and Annabelle all
coming home with the former two out for
worldwide release it's time to dive into
the conjuring universe once more to see
if there's anything behind this movie
other than smoke and mirrors throughout
this video I'll be breaking down
everything that you need to know about
the new horror movie and how I think it
sets up the conjuring 3 this is full
spoilers ahead so if you don't want to
know anything about the film then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video I
hope you enjoy it now sit back relax and
let's get into my breakdown of Annabelle
comes home
Annabelle comes home is the seventh
entry in the conjuring universe and it
stands as a kind of Greatest Hits of the
story so far however rather than
featuring the Warrens as the main
characters the story instead centers
around their daughter Judi who finds
herself in the middle of a demon home
invasion Judi is slowly developing her
sixth sense and is bullied because of
her parents obsession with the occult
juxtaposing this the majority of the
town in which they live have a fixation
with the Warrens and this aesthetic
slowly teases why the events in the film
happened after her parents leave town
for the night Judi is left with a
babysitter named Mary Ellen and a friend
Daniela who do to her curiosity decides
to touch everything in the house there
pretty much had a do not touch sign on
it worst babysitter ever it's revealed
later in the film that this is because
Daniela's father recently died and she
blames herself for the accident and she
just wants some closure
so yeah best thing for that is to
unleash the most evil demon on the
planet
well Dodie anyway we discover in the
film that Annabelle is not just a
conduit but rather a beacon for spirits
and through opening her case the house
is in for a whole host of new visitors
and this one that things will return
which I'll get into later Annabelle
wants to take over Judi and with her
developing psychic abilities this will
give her a lot more power there is an
ending that I had in my head that they
didn't do that I think
probably would have been better but due
to continuity and stuff they couldn't
really travel down that route anyway the
girls quickly realized that the only way
to stop Annabel the only way to contain
evil the only thing that can stop the
rise of hell is to put Annabel back in
the glass case again it is a bit
anticlimactic but this film has to reset
everything to the status quo and yeah I
can understand why they were forced into
this plot route eventually they managed
to get Annabel back in the case after
several demons including a badass
Samurai run amok in the house and scare
the crap out of everyone and the movie
ends with the Warrens returning and
throwing a party for judy who doesn't
think that anyone will come dude how
unpopular she is now I really wish that
the ending had have been actually had
actually been possessed by Annabel and
we just didn't know it and when the kids
show up she's just kind of murders them
off or bullying her but no we actually
get a pretty happy ending because Mary
Ellen and Daniella basically got their
friends together to make sure that it's
better than my super sweet 16
there's no post-credit scene and yet the
movie doesn't really definitively set up
anything down the line however going
forward there is a character introduced
in this film that was originally
confirmed as the villain for the
conjuring three back in 2017 that is the
hellhound whilst it might seem a bit
strange to have a werewolf as the main
villain in a film like this it actually
pulls from a real-life case that the
Warrens investigated Gary Doberman who
directed the film's stated that the
Warrens actually investigated a man that
was seemingly possessed by the spirit of
a werewolf and at some point he was
taken over by the man form and that
others he was taken control of by the
wolf this apparently happened in Essex
and Doberman said that during his
research he had found that along the
coast of the city a bed of fog and mist
circulated which would make the perfect
creepy story element me though I kind of
just hope it's the only way is Essex
with a really hairy guy in empo arel
that'll happen so zero percent on Rotten
Tomatoes for that movie anyway Doberman
said that the hellhound is in the
artifact room for a reason and to me
this definitely cements that the
creature will be returning for the third
film in the franchise which hopefully
will receive its trailer soon so what
did I think about the movie well since
the announcement of several films in the
during universe I've always wanted this
to be the MCU for horror fans something
that builds and builds towards a huge
climax that takes several elements of
horror and pulls them together in a
cohesive narrative however in reality
the conjuring universe is really
meddling and Annabelle comes home feels
like another unneeded entry that's not
really developing the plot beyond what
we've already seen and know about this
feels like it's been purely put in place
to set up sequels and spin-offs with new
characters and yet depending on how
excited you are that'll either leave you
pumped or rolling your eyes but all that
aside if you're a fan of the films
you'll either really love this or find
it really tiring it's nothing we haven't
seen before and your tolerance for this
will depend purely on how much you care
about jumpscares overall it's a fine
movie and I can definitely see myself
going back to this when I've got a quiet
night in and I just want something to
watch that I can chill out too and have
a take away with so yeah it's not gonna
revolutionize the horror genre it
doesn't really feel like anything
special it's fine but it's mindless fun
and further it gets a six point five out
of ten on the other hand if you're a 13
year old girl it'll probably be the
scariest movie that you've ever seen so
yeah for 13 year old girls 10 out of 10
Best Picture winner at the Academy
Awards obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the film and if there's
anything else that you took from the
ending comment below and let me know and
if you enjoyed this video then please
give it a thumbs up and make sure you
check out my breakdown of child's play
which would be linked at the end because
all of the ins and outs of the new
remake and it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more so
I'll leave that linked after this this
is the channel for people who are mad
into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best
see you next time take care peace it's
coming home it's coming home
it's coming Annabelle's coming home
[Music]
you